would you ever opt for healthy food
choices when you go get fast-food I have
definitely gotten a salad with like
nuggets to make myself feel better but I
think that actually doesn't
[Music]
I love those Wendy's frosting the
chocolate ones with french fries I eat
fast food less so now I opt for
healthier options when I can I feel like
because I'm vegetarian
I like naturally have a healthier option
in college I was so poor I would only
eat Wendy's for four for like once today
my relationship with Wendy's is kind of
like my ex they used to give me the bomb
kissing but don't give me the mom
kissing no more
so I have a rap I didn't know Wendy's
had this that's what I usually try to
find on on the fast food menus halo
literally cut a piece of grilled chicken
I just put it in there yeah with some
cheese it looks healthier than the
Baconator which is what I usually get
I had no idea Wendy's had a potato oh
yeah like a baked potato I knew about
the big potato yeah one of the things
are known for the frosty baked potato
sorry shall we it's cool I got you
Wendy's I think it has chives but no
broccoli and no cheese I was lied to I
think if I were like running around and
I actually just grabbed something really
quickly this would be satisfying ish
it's impressive it is impressive yeah no
one healthiest thing on this is the
cheese and like that's fine you know
gotta have some cheese I kind of want to
taste yours yeah
the bread on this too is good it's like
a pillow that covers the meat it's a
potato and I mean potatoes are great
kind of no matter what you do with them
all I'm so sorry so take another bite of
something that tastes good I would order
this again if they were french fries
that how that defeats the whole purpose
of being healthy but fries really make
the food I'm happy with this next time I
go to Wendy's I would totally order this
I'd still get a frosty because you got
it yeah but then I would still add two
of these if I was healthy and I was in a
rush I would order the chicken sandwich
again it's delicious I want to get this
because I just don't like fast food talk
to you if I was like in a potato moon
and I didn't want something as unhealthy
as like french fries this isn't a bad
option my opinion is slightly better now
now that I know they have these options
especially that I mean there's cheddar
and broccoli on that I would actually
order that so I think this is actually
like really great I think having more
healthier options will help people make
better choices because I live in a place
I have so many food options like this is
really cool but I'd rather just have
like really authentic tacos I feel like
I'm one of those people that thinks
there's a balance like I don't think you
need to avoid fast food thing it's more
about like what you choose
the decisions you make and I also just
think everything in moderation and like
you can kind of indulge one day and then
go healthier another day
[Music]